c'est l'un des plus célèbres monuments à
bourges est l'un des plus visités le
palais jacques coeur la célèbre devise
du grand argentier de charles cette
figure sur la façade
à coeur vaillant rien d'impossible mais
bien peu savent que jacques coeur fils
de commerçant n'a pas pu habiter dans
cet fastueuses demeures qui porte
pourtant ce moment c'est bien ont été
mis sous séquestre confisqué par le roi
au moment de l'arrestation de jacques
coeur et donc ni sa femme toute façon
qui est morte peu de temps après nice et
enfants ont pu profiter ce formidable
hôtel
c'est un peu ça david jacques coeur
c'est au fond un grand rêve qu'il a
voulu montrer une tout d'un coup il à
rêver sa vie ensuite mis en application
ses rêves jusqu'à quelque part à la
chute du rêve ensuite et d'abus en tous
cas construire son palais à l'image de
sa réussite
ces armoiries le coeur et la coquille
sont représentés dans la salle des
festins jacques coeur avait délégué la
construction de son palais aux meilleurs
architectes et artisans sa femme restée
à bourges
surveillez aussi l'avancée des travaux
au moment de son procès le palais n'est
qu'une infime partie des propriétés
amassés grâce à ces lettres de crédit
auprès des noble désargenté end oblation
voulait parce que bien sûr la noblesse
supportait mal de devoir beaucoup
parfois beaucoup d'argent à personne
clôture hier un simple marchand à
l'origine et bien sûr jalouse et le
pouvoir et la place qu'il avait pris au
sein même du conseil royal
jacques coeur battait monnaie pour le
roi grand voyageur ses richesses
promener de son commerce avec le vent
les actuels côtes syriennes libanaises
égyptienne de ses expéditions il ramène
aussi des idées d'aménagement originale
pour son palais comme un hammam une
petite pièce située juste à côté de la
cuisine à côté on a une pièce qui est à
peu près 60 cm surélevée et donc ici
dans cet événement ont fait un foyer on
chauffe le sol ici on verse de l'eau qui
tombe sur ce sol chaud et donc on avait
donc un bain de vapeur ce qui va être
extraordinaire tout c'est d'avoir un
bain de vapeur à titre privé chez lui
voilà pour l'histoire officielle
mais depuis plus de 500 ans le palais a
été largement remanié
direction donc les sous sols des lieux
interdits aux yeux des visiteurs où l'on
peut faire de drôles de rencontres ça
c'est les petits trésors du palais est
en fait là vous avez en fait d un tout
un dépôt lapidaire
alors il ya des pièces du monument des
originaux notamment celle ci en fait
vous avez la vraie masse etc et sur la
façade est de la rue parce qu'en fait
c'est cette dame en fête a été refaite
et donc l'original en fait
et ici masse et les hôtes par la femme
de jacques coeur reposent à même le sol
on croise aussi d'étranges gargouille
plus ou moins effrayante et même un
vitrail de la cathédrale qui attend sa
nouvelle affectation
là des moulages viennent du motel deux
échevins du musée du berry et d'autres
monuments en fait qu'ils sont même deux
lors de fouilles de qu'on a qu'on a
récupéré sait pas trop d'où ils viennent
et on les a stocké ici parce que chez
nous on jette rien un étage plus bas
c'est un peu le cimetière des pierres
les campagnes de fouilles préventives
sont asti si loin des regards
vous avez un morceau de pâte avec des
griffes alors d'où ça vient ça je serais
bien incapable de vous de vous le dire
on a aussi le reste d'un calvaire n'a
juste ici bien la croire on a toute une
série da c'est pareil la couronne aussi
avec des emblèmes et des belles petites
pièces en fait mais alors le problème de
savoir d'où elle vient d'où elles
proviennent
je serai bien normal de vous le dire
notre visite se poursuit au troisième
sous-sol à 20 mètres au-dessous de la
cour d'honneur l'eau commence même à
cimenter sur les murs on est dans un des
ces fameux souterrains de la ville pour
fantasmer les gens et donc cette partie
là est antérieure au palais est en fait
il donnait à l'origine donc sur un puits
qui maintenant est condamné retour à la
surface
les appartements privés sont séparés des
salons d'apparat par une dizaine
d'escalier d'anciennes pièces où on
rendait la justice
certes aujourd'hui de simples bureaux
comme celui de l'administratrice placé
devant une immense cheminée sous les
armoiries de jacques coeur et de
napoléon on a rarement l'occasion de
travailler dans ces conditions mais ça
fait aussi partie de
des privilèges de travailler pour le
patrimoine donc évidemment des monuments
historiques
c'est un petit peu lourd à porter on va
dire notre époque mais
on est ravi évidemment
autre pièce inaccessible aux touristes
ces combles autrefois lambrissés qui
pouvait accueillir le personnel de la
cour
nous sommes dans la tour sud aujourd'hui
c'est l'endroit préféré des chauves
souris
même la tête en bas elles ont une vue
imprenable sur la cathédrale